i had worked for neil simon
you know back in the 80s when i was
mostly doing theater in new york
and i had a lovely
time with him but we never got close but
somehow i was invited during the
seinfeld years to his home
for to celebrate a birthday of this and
i was the only person there i'd never
heard of you know so
and johnny carson was there
and i
so wanted to talk to him and just say
thank you for all that all those
wonderful years but i was very
intimidated he's not gonna know who i am
and you know he gets bothered all the
time and i sort of psyched myself out
and the third time i passed him he got
up
and said i just want to say uh i love
your work on the show and i was like oh
my god oh my god oh my god and now i had
to like make up the excuses for why i
had walked by him two times without
saying anything so i was so intimidated
i didn't want to bother you
but yeah i um
i'll tell you the one that killed me
killed me um i had never met dick van
dyke
up to the point of this story but i
i did a tv movie by birdie in the role
that he created
and it went on the air and it was fun it
was fine i was proud of it it was fun
and the following day i don't know how
he got my address i got flowers and a
bottle of champagne and a note instead
dear jason now i know how to play the
role thank you you were great big van
dyke and i went oh come on come on
that's it's that's stupid do you do you
save things like that
yes i save all this i saved if
somebody wrote a letter so i took a
picture with someone it's on the wall
yeah you bet because i've always felt
like my career could be over tomorrow
that's it every time i'm working
tomorrow and at least i'll have you know
being a fan i'll have all this in my
house like a museum and i could say to
somebody one day i met that person i did
absolutely yeah you what's what's the
one thing you have at your house
that you keep
um i have a bunch of stuff
the stuff
that i really kind of put out that i
don't have in a book somewhere
you